[Музика]
знову привіт
ось ми з вами Оксана Маленко та
Mr.  поло разом для шкільного життя в
п'ятий рік,
привіт, п'ятий рік, так, на минулому уроці
ми говорили про те, наскільки
ви добре навчаєтеся, і ми провели вікторину, і
я сподіваюся, що ми дали вам поживу для роздумів
саме щодо вашої провини.
Ви спробуєте пояснити,
що це означає для наших студентів, так як
їжа живить ваше тіло, а ця помилка
живить ваш мозок саме так, ми
сподіваємося, що ми дамо вам над чим подумати
на
основі результатів нашої вікторини та,
можливо, після  Результати цієї
вікторини ви захочете самі стати кращим
учнем, сьогодні ми рухаємося далі,
і ми будемо говорити про незвичайні
школи по всьому світу, у які ви не
повірите, але існує дуже багато навіть дивних
закладів, які навчають своїх учнів
абсолютно  ненормальні речі, що означають
ненормальні, а не звичайні, чи можете ви вгадати,
про що ми сьогодні будемо говорити,
можливо, є деякі школи
, які схожі на навички викладання, які ви
не використовуєте в школі за межами школи  шкільні
навички, можливо, якісь інші ідеї, можливо,
є деякі школи, наприклад, деякі
акторські школи, тож ви можете бути актором,
так, це також може бути.
Марс ні, поки ми ще не
готові їх розпочати, я думаю, Ілін
маска все ще працює над цим проектом,
добре, давайте почнемо, перш ніж ми перейдемо
до теми нашого уроку, я б хотів, щоб ми
мали приємну діяльність, це іноді список п’ятірки
психологи кажуть нам,
чому б вам не створити список плюсів
і мінусів, щоб вирішити,
хороша ідея чи погана, і тепер я знаю, що, будучи
вечірньою людиною, пам'ятайте, що я годинна
людина, я зовсім не люблю ранок, чого
хотів  спати, і ось мій
список п'ятірки ах, ось чому він на твоїй
стороні правління, а цей для мене, який
любить бути таким, на цьому боці
дошки, впевнений, що ти мене зламав, так що п'ять
причин моїх причин залишитися в  лягай
вранці, щоб ти знав, що я  вчитель, я люблю
свою роботу, але прокидаюся, готуюся,
готуючись до сніданку,
це великий стрес для мене, тому це шкільний
день, і це чудова причина для
мене залишатися в ліжку довше, я не хочу йти
в пробці, але  для мене у мене є п'ять
причин вставати з ліжка, тому що це
шкільний день причина номер один, щоб встати
з ліжка, і я не маю проблем із
затори, тому що я встаю дуже рано,
тому що я так схвильований, щоб йти до школи, я
хочу  йти до школи спочатку й рано, щоб
не було заторів, коли я йду дуже рано
вранці, о, я б хотів, щоб у мене була така ж
ситуація, тому моя друга причина залишатися
спати: хм, я не вивчав історію,
але це
секрет, не  розкажи це комусь історія один
з моїх улюблених предметів, коли вивчаєш
історію, ти дізнаєшся про дати та відомі
битви, і завжди вчишся
з помилок, які люди робили в історії,
перш ніж писати, і моя причина номер
три – це рибний день у школі, в якій
я навчаюся  всі OH
на моїй шкільній вечері  вони дивовижні
кожен день, але коли це день брауні
, це найважливіша причина ходити
до школи, брауні щасливі, що ти
встав номер чотири, щоб я залишався в ліжку,
це мій друг захворів і не
прийде до школи з ким я буду говорити
о, мій друг може захворів, але це
не має значення, тому що після школи
я поспішаю додому і розповім їм
про все, що дізнався, о, це
дуже чудова причина йти до школи і ще
одна причина, чому надворі йде дощ, але
коли  іде дощ і сонце, ти бачиш
веселку, тому я можу вийти подивитися на веселку
і спробувати знайти горщик із золотом, який
є кінцем кожної
веселки.
Святого Патрика ми дізнаємося про це на наших
попередніх заняттях, право Mr.  опитування, ти
такий позитивний і ентузіазм
вранці, я б хотів, щоб я був хоча б наполовину таким же
позитивним, як ти ракета Йона, я б
хотів, щоб я був таким же енергійним, як ти,
ввечері, тому що після чотирьох п'яти шостого чи
семи я так втомився
о  мій, це найпродуктивніша
частина дня для мене добре, хлопці, ви бачите,
це дуже хороший спосіб вирішити, чи
потрібно вам це робити чи ні, ви можете подивитися
на всі сумні причини, які закликають вас
не робити цього  зробіть це, і,
навпаки, ви можете подивитися на мої п’ять
надихаючих причин встати з ліжка і точно
йти до школи
, і я впевнений, що ви
захочете встати з ліжка,
коли дізнаєтесь про школи, які ми
підготували для вас  сьогодні ось кілька
підказок для вас, і ви спробуєте
зламати слова, які я закодував для вас, на всяк
випадок, якщо ви не зрозуміли, це інші
зображення, і я скажу вам підказку, що всі
ці слова записані у зворотному напрямку
означає, що вони починаються не з першої
літери, а з останньої, тому mr.
Пол, ти вже зрозумів, про які
школи ми сьогодні будемо говорити,
так, безперечно, перші дві, які я
вже прочитав правильно, тому я бачу,
що перша говорить про магічну, правильно
, це магічна школа, про яку ми
сьогодні дізнаємося,  другий каже,
майбутня майбутня школа, я
помилився чи мечеть Еллен побудувала школу на
Марсі, ми дізнаємося добре, а що щодо
двох інших, ну ця була трохи
складна, але коли я побачив картинку, я
зрозумів, що це як  поганий
цирк, тож це школа клоунів,
точно це школа клоунів і
остання дуже незвичайна
ця школа, яку я чув про цю школу
вони йдуть, і перша
група шкіл, про яку ми збираємося дізнатись
, це магічні школи, ви бачите,
що в світі не тільки одна,
їх мінімум дві, давайте з'ясуємо,
де вони і чому навчають
свого учня  s Mr.  Пол, ти допоможеш нам
читати так, звичайно, я добре
, є різні магічні школи, такі
як школа відьом, велика школа
чаклунства в США та школа ельфів
в Ісландії, вони навчають вас двом незвичайним
речам, наприклад, створенню і шепоту коней про
історію ельфів  і що означає, що
студенти навіть отримають сертифікати та
стануть експертами в обраній галузі
навчання. Вау,
мені цікаво, де я міг би застосувати свої
знання в історії ельфів, ельфів, щоб ви
могли допомогти Санта-Клаусу ах, можливо, знайти та
найняти ельфів для роботи або бути
ними  Представляйте і вимагайте більше
подарунків для дітей,
так, хороша ідея, це, хлопці,
чи ви зрозуміли, що робить, коли
ви згадаєте, що в Гаррі Поттері у нього є
чи всі учні мають ці чарівні
палички, я думаю, вони мені потрібні англійською,
коли у вас є  одна магічна, у нас
є фраза, я не знаю, чи це
фраза, яку ви створили, але якщо ви
хочете створити якусь магію, ви кажете
абракадабра так, у нас вона була, я думаю, і
іноді ми використовуємо  d це насправді ця
абракадабра так, це так правильно, коли
ми робимо паличку, ми робимо чарівну палицю,
щоб надіти чоловіка.
трюк, коли чарівник
щось розповідає тварині, і вони
роблять ці дії, наскільки вони
зрозуміли, а заклинання відьми
ви пам'ятаєте на Хеллоуїн,
всі добрі відьми мають великий холод,
а потім ставлять сходи, якісь жаби Соленого
пишуть якісь незвичайні речі  а потім вони
починають змішувати це разом і вимовляти кілька
слів, тож це змушує їх чаклувати,
коли ти хочеш, щоб щось
сталося, ти роби це заклинанням, я правий
так, ти можеш підштовхнути, але ти можеш, деякі люди
роблять добрі заклинання так, не будуть говорити
про  люди, які роблять погані заклинання ні не
в цьому класі, добре, і чи можете ви
повірити, що вони навіть отримають сертифікат,
який є документом, який підтверджує, що ви
є експертом у цій галузі навчання,
як г-м-м.  Пол, ти б хотів бути,
хм
, експертом з ельфів, це звучить цікаво, але
той, який я віддаю перевагу, більше подобається бути
чарівником, чаклунством, щоб я міг
заклинати людей і приносити людям удачу.
Ви знаєте, що це
мене більше подобається, так, наступна школа, про яку ми
збираємося говорити, - це Філадельфійська
школа майбутнього, тому ця школа
абсолютно відрізняється від будь-якої іншої
школи в світі, тому це означає, що
вони відрізняються від традиційних
шкіл у всіх відношеннях  для початку вони
користуються лотереєю, ви можете повірити, щоб
вирішити, хто приєднається до їхньої школи,
це просто пощастило,
можливо, у них так багато людей, які
хочуть піти, саме тому вони це роблять так, можливо,
тоді у них немає  Оцінки у них не
дуже високі, тому, наприклад, учень у
цій школі не може отримати дві, п’ять чи 12,
тому що вони мають свою власну систему
оцінювання, і їхні оцінки починаються з того, що не
на радарі, що, я думаю, означає дуже
низький результат для просування  це чудово,
тому учням насправді не потрібні
книги, тому вони не витрачають папір
і дбають про навколишнє середовище, тому що
вони використовують комп’ютери, лабораторія,
ну, планшети та спеціальні
програми для вивчення математики, то що
ви думаєте про цю школу?  вважаю,
що деякі школи по всьому світу вже
схожі на цю майбутню школу так, я
згоден з вами, але з іншого боку,
що роблять діти, якщо у них немає
електрики,
хм, бачите, переконайтеся, що вони заряджають
ноутбуки напередодні ввечері так,
можливо, іноді  Стара добра книга -
найкращий помічник у навчанні, хто знає, ми
побачимо, коли час пройде, і остання
школа, про яку ми сьогодні будемо говорити,
це такі школи, які можна знайти в
Бангладеш, тому що двічі на рік повінь,
коли діти не можуть ходити до школи  ці
школи мають комп’ютерне підключення до Інтернету,
невелику бібліотеку та працюють
на сонячних батареях, це школа на човнах
у Бангладеш, це дуже
цікава ідея щодо створення школи
на  човен, але ви бачите, що це не
дитяча ідея ходити в цю школу
через погодні умови, і
я впевнений, що наші розумні п'ятирічки
пам'ятають, що таке повінь, так що повінь
я просто нагадаю вам, що топ Льоня
коли йде багато дощів, і територія навколо
вас покривається водою, ви ніби
перебуваєте на березі річки, а Бангладеш є
однією з найнижчих країн
світу і знаходиться в Бенгальській затоці,
закони про повені, пам’ятаєте, містер.  Чесно кажучи, Пол є
експертом з географії, тож ти
хотів би бути вчителем у якій-небудь зі
шкіл, якщо чесно, я думаю, що я б
вибрав цю в Бангладеш, тому що
це інше, це цікаво, і, перш
за все, ти повинен бути дуже добрим
учителем  робота на човні в поганих
умовах погане обладнання,
тому я вважаю, що це складніше і
складніше. Цар хороші виклики
хороші для подолання правильних викликів
проблеми, тому Metropole вважає, що перебування
в таких умовах і складність
покращує вашу особистість docto
colino вигідно  Ваня Васа так
змарнував місто, щоб мати Раю добре,
і зараз у нас буде
дуже незвичайне завдання, тому що у нас буде
троє учнів з різних країн,
які навчатимуться в одному після школи вище Mr.
поло буде так люб'язно прочитати
повідомлення учнів, і нам потрібно буде
вирішити, яку зі згаданих шкіл
вони відвідують зараз,
давайте переглянемо назви школи,
щоб магічні школи для чарівників
і експертів зі здоров'я Філадельфійська
школа майбутнього були студентами
використовувати комп’ютери та додатки для навчання,
а також школу Бангладеш, коли
учням потрібно відправитися на човен, щоб зустріти
свого вчителя та отримати знання, а тепер
давайте подивимося на назви цих
трьох.
Андрія та на Mr.
збоку лапки є картинки, які
допоможуть вам згадати школи, які ми
обговорювали раніше, тому Mr.  Пол
, будь ласка, допоможіть нашим учням
покращити свої навички аудіювання та
визначити, в яку школу навчається кожен із
учнів. Я не часто користуюся книгами,
тому що завжди можу знайти
потрібну інформацію на своєму ноутбуці, коли мені
потрібно написати твір англійською мовою.  використовувати
службу написання есе в коледжі також
дуже весело, щоб створити інтерактивний
проект і представити його на розумній дошці.
Гаразд, я думаю, коли ви взяли до
уваги слова без книг, ноутбук онлайн
, служба написання клітинок і розумна дошка,
тож я думаю, що це був легкий вибір для
ви і вас звуть у школі
Джейк ходить у так китті добре кошеня наша
школа не звичайна, тому що ми не
вивчаємо традиційні шкільні предмети,
замість цього ми читаємо Гаррі Поттера
на уроках навчання грамоти, а також
у нашій школі немає класів, у нас
чотири будинки  названий на честь чарівних
істот, добре, ви чули основну
інформацію про Гаррі Поттера
немає традиційних класів магічних істот,
тому відповідь очевидна, я думаю, і
Ендрю
два рази на так  r Я не можу ходити до школи,
тому що все навколо мого дому перетворилося
на величезну річку, чи можете ви повірити, що
школа приходить до мене, це дуже приємно,
тому що я можу бачити свого вчителя і позичати
кілька книг з нашої маленької бібліотеки, щоб
правильно читати, тому це легко  вибір,
тому що ви чули слова вода
школа приходить до студента маленька
бібліотека торкніться вчителя і
позичайте книги, щоб читати добре, зараз
я покажу вам відповіді, а ви
перевірите, чи були ви правильні чи ні, тому Джейк
йде до школи Філадельфії
майбутня Кітті відвідує магічну школу,
а Ендрю ходить до школи човнів, я
сподіваюся, що всі ви отримали правильні відповіді,
і ми рухаємося далі, хлопці,
тому сьогодні ми подивимося на
фрази, які вживаються на
початку речення  щоб розповісти про місцезнаходження
людини або предмета в якомусь місці, ці
фрази є чотири однини, які
означають один або незлічений іменник mr.  Павло,
давайте нагадаємо нашим учням, що
таке незліченний іменник добре, тож, наприклад,
вода цукор, вам потрібен інший
опис перед ним, як чашка
води два кубики цукру, ви не можете просто
сказати одна вода, шість вода, п’ять цукру, ви
повинні сказати a  чашка або ложка, яку ви повинні
сказати, описуючи слово перед словом зараз
мм-хм, так це те,
що ми не можемо порахувати, не
вводячи спеціального вимірювання, як-от
чашка чи чайна ложка коліки чи кілограм,
так що пам’ятайте, що є плюс
однина, що є одним або незлічуваним
іменником, як у прикладі є
магічна школа, одна школа в однині в
Ісландії або там багато
інформації інформація є незліченні іменник
ми не можемо порахувати нам потрібна частина
інформації або байт інформації
прямо в Інтернеті наступний
нуль використовується з множиною злічених
іменників, тому об’єкти, які ми можемо порахувати,
як 1 2 3 4 5 без додаткових
слів, оскільки в прикладі існує багато
незвичайних шкіл навколо  світ, тож
це школи, ми можемо нарахувати їх одну школу
до шкіл, три школи і так далі, і
так далі, добре, зараз ми
перевіримо, наскільки добре ви зрозуміли цей
граматичний феномен, і виконаємо деякі
вправи, тому це не дуже складно тут, у
нас буде  позитивні речення
заперечні речення з заперечною
часткою not like there is not or there
оранжеве та питальне речення, коли ми
хочемо запитати про місцезнаходження того
чи іншого предмета чи особи перший
багато учнів у відьмі,
щоб у нас було багато  зі студентів багато з
них буде множиною, тож, ймовірно, тут
нам потрібно буде використати слово «
о правильно», щоб у нашій школі воно було там або в
наступній будь-якій формі, щоб ми могли
носити те, що хочемо, наприклад джинси та
футболки  якщо вони праві, що, на
вашу думку, буде негативним так, тому
немає, немає, тому що уніформа
незлічена, ми не можемо порахувати форму
правильно, добре, тоді наступне питання - це
запитання багатьох учнів у вашій
школі ельфів  тому ми починаємо з дієслова, так що
вони правильні, як тут номер для звичайних
оцінок у нашій школі, але смішні фрази,
як-от не на їхній радарі, це знову негативний,
тому немає точно негативного
синього та нічого незвичайного у
вашій школі, що знову є  питання, тож
ми починаємо з дієслова чи є мм-хм,
добре,
тепер давайте подивимося на всі відповіді
разом, ми такі нещасні,
звичайно, ви були абсолютно праві,
тепер давайте спробуємо відповісти на це запитання
нещасний, якщо є щось незвичайне
у школі, яку ви  навчати наразі
те, що закрито через крон, це
незвично, у нас дуже маленькі
класи, тому у нас від 8 до 10 учнів,
тому це дуже добре для навчання, і у нас
є багато уроків природничих наук, тому дуже
дуже цікаві уроки природничих наук, тож
принаймні  у вас багато експериментів
так так добре, хлопці, тепер завдання для
вас полягає в тому, чому б вам не подумати і не спробувати
самі відповісти на це питання, що
незвичайного у
вашій школі я впевнений, що є один
або два  o речі, які відрізняють вашу школу
від усіх інших шкіл по
Україні, подумайте про це та напишіть свою
відповідь. Щиро дякую
сьогодні ми закінчуємо наш урок, дякую, що
ви з нами, пане.  pollow
Дякую u5i та Оксана навіть прибуток, який було
дуже приємно вчитися разом з
тобою в зеленому скотчі Cola онлайн до побачення
[Музика]
ти